hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website comm and today we're gonna
be looking in on day number two of the
2017 champions showdown this is a
head-to-head battle there's eight of the
top chess players in the world they're
matched up against one individual person
and they play that individual through 30
games over a four-day span our
competitors that we're gonna be looking
at today is Nakamura verse topalov in
day one they played four games of rapid
chess at 30 minutes apiece there is no
time increment on top of that so it's 30
moves or 30 minutes for all of their
moves and both sides got a victory
Nakamura had two victories
topalov had one victory and they tied
one so Nakamura is up a game there's
different points awarded for each day
when you get a win but all things
created equal
just know that Nakamura is up a game
overall after day one so we're gonna be
looking at a day number two and Nakamura
starting off game number one that we're
gonna be looking at today and he has the
white pieces he starts out with puns to
e4 and so blob responds with pawn to c5
now both of these players have played a
little bit different than what we're
used to seeing from top level play we've
seen Nakamura defend against the pawn he
for from topple op all tournament with
pawn to c6 and top blob has tried his
own variations but today he's trying
something different I was playing the
Sicilian defense so we see pawn to c5
Sicilian offense Knight f3 pawn d6
upon d4 capture Knight recaptures here
on d4 Knight f6 and then Knight to c3
this is the open Sicilian this is the
main line this is probably what 80 85
percent of Sicilian games go down the
path of and from here is where most
people would say you know what type of
Sicilian defense did they played they
was it a knight or fins with pawn to a6
was it more of a classical defense with
Knight to c6 or did they try to be more
aggressive
with a dragon defensive pawn to g6 or
was an accelerated dragon and they
played pawn to g6 a move before this and
this is where we start to say okay this
is this is what it was and Nakamura
decided to go ahead and play pawn to a6
this is the night door of defense this
is the most popular that you see at a
high-level play and there's lots of ways
that white can to respond to this the
pawn to a6 stops a lot of the threats
that white wants to have his both of his
knights a and his bishop can easily come
to b5 put a lot of pressure on the King
because it's gonna be a few moves before
the King can castle on the King side
this pawn here on e7 is blocking the
bishop so it's gonna be a while before
castle on the Kings side very important
square for this pawn on a6 to come to to
stop any threats coming to this b5
square Y can bring his Bishop to c4
start to attack this f7 squared which is
weakened early on because the King is
the only piece that's that's defending
this could even come Bishop to e3 start
to develop his pieces on the queenside
castle on the Queen set if he wanted to
but to blogeee decides to play a little
bit differently and play pawn to f3 not
something we generally see too often
from white but this is a rapid game and
they only have 20 minutes today so not a
lot of time for each of these players to
be thinking and so you can see a lot of
the preparation that comes in from both
sides because they don't have time to
think it's all about what they studied
and came prepared for macklemore
responds with pawn to e6 some of the
other moves you may see in this position
would be pawn to e5 is fine more that
classical Knight to c6 as we talked
about before or even if you want to get
your Queen involve Queen to b6
threatening the center of the board
is also popular but this had to go and
play pawn to e6 Bishop here III and then
pawn to h5 so you can tell Nakamura has
a plan in place he's not gonna be
castling on the Queen side because he's
already has the semi open file losing
his pawn on the C file so Pont h5 even
says I may not castle on the King side
of the
or but I'm gonna be pretty aggressive
starting to attack my opponent from
White's perspective he looks at this
he's already weakened his King said the
board with pawns f3 so he's more than
likely gonna be looking to castle on the
Queen side start to attack his opponent
on the King side of the board topple off
Bishop to c4 developing getting into the
center of the board Queen here to c7
Bishop back here b3 this is where Bobby
Fischer used to bring his Bishop back
quite often against the Sicilian defense
many times the next move for him would
be pawn to a 3 and he would even hide
his Bishop back on a2 really liked it to
control this long light square diagonal
here from white but brings it back here
to Bishop b3 knight c6 just simple
development Queen to d2 opening up the
opportunity to castle on the Queen's
head if he wants to Bishop e7 casts on
the Queen side Knight to a5 attacking
the bishop right here and decided to go
ahead and bring his King over here to be
one wants to make sure that it is
protecting this a2 pawn if it needs to
because the bishop can fall at any time
from the knight Bishop to d7 completing
his development here besides the the
castling of his King pawn to g2 just
pushing forward a little bit and then we
see pawn b5 so both sides recognizing
where they want to attack black nakamora
looking to attack on the Queen side the
board and topalov saying yeah I know
you're not gonna cast on the Queen side
I'm gonna start pushing over here on the
King side of the board pawn to h3 just
consolidating the control of the g4
square right here and then pawn to b4
just starting to attack his opponent
even further starting to force him to
move Knight comes back here to e2 had
some other options could've easily
played Knight to a4 then Knight takes on
b3 we see in exchange pawn recaptures on
b3 Queen down here 85 if he wanted to
now starting to attack on the King side
of the board but decides to maybe I
wouldn't say play it safe but decides
not to worry about this
attack going on the queenside the board
and just bring his knight back here to
e2 positioning to attack on the kingside
the board pawn to e5 and this is getting
the defender from this bishop here on b3
black does want to exchange here on b3
but if he were to just exchange right
away then the knight could recapture
here on a b3 and white has a pretty fine
position he doesn't have to give up any
of his pawns as far as a double pawn
structure weaken his queen side of the
board so black recognizes this and says
let's first move that night out of the
way with a simple move pawn to e5 always
be looking on your games to see how is
my opponent going to recapture if
they're gonna recapture with one of
their minor pieces in this particular
case a Knights how do I get that night
away from the square this is a great
place for Nakamura to move that night
Knight comes over here to f5 and then we
see the capture here on b3 now what was
surprising is how Topal I've decided to
recapture many times if it's not a
sinner pawn you're gonna be capturing
towards the center of the board
meaning pawn to b3 this also makes it
more difficult for your opponent right
here to attack any vulnerability of your
King but he decided to go ahead and take
with his C pawn away from the center of
the board I think this does open him up
for some strong attacks especially with
his opponent still having two of his
bishops on board so curious uh you know
from Tablas perspective as he was
preparing for this variation why he
decided to go with pawn takes on b3 not
the most common move that we see Bishop
takes here on f5 we see the pawn
recaptured Queen over here to b7
attacking this pawn right here forcing
the work to come over f1 so you can see
Nakamura starting to be the aggressor
and white really being more of the
playing defense getting his rook behind
to defend and just waiting to see what
Nakamura does black starts to push
forward with pawn to d5 one of his past
pawns on the board punt up here to F 4
and then pawn d4 if you have a
spawn one of the rules in Jess's
continued to push that and just put more
pressure on your opponent this gives
black more space starts to just mitigate
the opportunities that White has to
really develop their pieces and control
the center of the board black has full
control the stern of the board right
here and you can see that black forcing
white to come back here to g1 probably
worse if he takes let's say pawn takes
on e5 and then pawn recaptures here on
e3 Queen takes Knight here to d5 now
he's really really pressuring his
opponents why the sides let's not do
that instead decide to go and bring his
Bishop back here to g1 now Knight to e4
attacking the Queen Queen comes back
here to e1 and then pawn f6 solidifying
the pawn chain right here from black
pawn takes pawn recaptures knight back
here to c1 so toe cloth is sitting back
here with all of his material on the
first rank nakamura sitting with two
central pawns both of which are passed
pawns he has all of his pieces in the
center of the board
only his rooks back here on the eighth
rank so all things considered black
definitely has an advantage and tebab is
going to have to to really maneuver
around to get out of this predicament
nakamura decides to get castle on the
kingside this is not for a king side
safety but he just wants to make sure
that his rooks gonna be coming over here
and for the time being thinks it's a
little bit better with this King here on
a g8 than it is here on eh pawn up to a
g4 so says yeah I gotta attack on the
the King side of the board I have really
nothing else going for me none of my
pieces can be coordinated because
they're all here on the first rank and
then you see pawn a5 says okay let's
attack on the Queen side of the board
Bishop h1 attacking the pawn bishop here
to d6 now essential square for the dark
square and for nakamora his bishops
really just playing defense right now
but it's locking down and making sure
the
controls the center of the board with
these ponds so cloth pushes forward
Queen 2 e 2 upon H 4 rook here 2 e 1
night down here a g3 hit is an outpost
with the pawn here it's hacking the
Queen Y decides let's go ahead and
exchange that material and that's
completely fine with nakamura pawn to g3
just another thing for white to worry
about while it's gonna be difficult to
hold on to this pawn because there's so
much material that y can throw at it
that really just allows black to focus
on the center of the board and make
white spend some time and energy to take
care of this pawn here on a g3 so Queen
up here to e4 and nakamura says that's
completely fine well if i don't have to
worry about your queen i'm gonna win
just because I have sinner control and I
can really put a lot of pressure on you
my bishops going to be better
there's pawns all over the board it can
control the board a little bit better
than one night which does tend to fare
better if there's just pawns on one side
of the board he can hop around and
control just one side of the board a lot
easier rook takes here on e4 and then
pawn a g6 Knight up here to d3 attacking
the pawn but the bishop is doing a good
job holding that down pawns who a g2 and
then work over here g1 using a couple
moves from white to take back this
material pawn takes on f5 pawn
recaptures Rick comes down here to f5
and then you can see two moves from
white to get this material and both
sides are equal in material but black
has a better pawn structure two pawns
and they're so the board they're both
passed yes white does have a passed pawn
over here on the H file but just doesn't
have as much support for that and then
he'd has double pawns here on the B file
so gonna be very difficult for two bluff
to hold on to this especially with
nakamora being such a very good rapid
player he's used to these type of
positions and extending his lead with
little time on the clock King to f7 with
the Queen's off the board decides it's
now time to get his King involved into
the board work over here to e2 King
here f6 and knights f2 rook to c8 punt
up here to h4 he has to try something
but it's just so difficult to find a
great move rook down here at three work
over to g4 not really sure what he's
doing as soon as you have these rooks no
longer connected they're just so much
weaker than they were before
rook to e3 attacking this says yeah I
would love to just exchange right here
bring my pawn down to e3 you have to
worry about that then I can really apply
my dark-squared bishop to defend that
square here on e3 rook to e4 says I'm
not gonna be doing that but hey that's
fine I'm just gonna make sure that you
go down even more material cuz I think I
can win this in game pawn to f5 met up
here to e4 Bishop e7 attacking this pawn
here on h4 now back to g3 attacking the
King King to e6 just centralizing this
is great for black because his King is
involved the King here on b1 he can't
get involved it's blocked off because
this rook here is on c8 so really really
making sure that white can't get all of
his pieces involved in to the action
right here pawn up to h5 a bishop down
to a g5 getting ready if he wants to
with a threat of rook to c1 checkmate
has to stop that threat rook to c2
decides okay don't worry about that I'm
gonna come to the other open font which
is the F file currently rook to f8
getting ready to swing down and attack
his opponent pawn up to a four king to a
d5 Ruka up here to c7 rook down here to
f3 and at this particular points white
decides to resign he sees no way to
really hold on to the game just doesn't
think it's gonna go well
and so decides to go ahead and give
knock more than one so nakamura at this
point is up two games on his opponent
always good coming into day two to win
the first game as the black pieces
sometimes people always ask well why
would someone
resign in a position and just if you're
not seeing exactly what's gonna happen
tow blob is not able to hold on to this
night here on g3 and so let's let's look
at where he could go
the first option we see which is
completely awful because he would lose
his efore Kings gonna take it comes up
here to f5
then the rook is gonna take it if it
comes down here to h1 then rook f1 check
he's going to lose the knight right here
if he decides to play Knight to e2 then
pawn d3 just puts nail on the coffin as
we talked about before and I can't come
down here to g1 cuz rook to f1 that's
gonna be bad he comes up to G g3 or f4
is going to lose it as well from the
rook if he comes to c3 he's gonna lose
it from the pawn and if he comes back
here to see one then rook to f1 with the
threat of the the rook taking even the
bishop taking and most notably just a
pawn coming down here to d2 depending on
where the rook is the Brooke may try to
chase the King around the board they can
always just hide behind here on e4 but
assuming the the rook is still there
could always just play pawn to d2 the
knight can't move it's pinned down and
so all going to end up losing if the
King moves and you can kind of see
what's gonna happen then well I can just
easily take this material right here so
at the end of the day Topol off knew he
was gonna lose that night not gonna go
well Nakamura still has these two pawns
in this side of the board he can push up
and get an easy victory here so that is
the first game on day 2 and they're
playing 6 on day two quite a few games
going on on day 2
but hopefully guys enjoyed this game one
of the more exciting games we've seen in
a while we just don't see a lot of
Sicilian offense especially the knight
orth defense so always good to see
something different and some of the
preparation that both of these players
have coming into the champions showdown
thanks for watching I'll see you in the
next video